hedge funds have absolutely been losing
compared to the s p 500 in 2021 that's
right all of those smart geniuses all
those people calculating all the numbers
on wall street they lost the s p 500
outperforming majority of hedge funds
what do i mean the s p 500 has returned
29
this year massive move for the s p
compared to historical numbers only
three hedge funds of the major hedge
funds actually beat the s p 500. if we
go ahead and we look at the list itself
these are some of the best hedge funds
in the world go ahead and look at it
we've got send best we've got third
point we've got citadel we've got d1
capital we've got two sigma .72
renaissance all of them tiger global
bridgewater brevan howard element roku's
melvin capital i mean melvin capital has
41 this year whoa and so if you go ahead
and you look at this the s p 500
outperformed everybody but three hedge
funds on this list now if we go and we
look at actual hedge funds themselves
there's about 4.5 trillion dollars in
hedge fund aum now if you do a very
simple calculation they get paid 2 and
20 on most of these hedge funds that is
a hell of a lot of money now if you are
paying them you expect out performance
you don't expect them to lose to the s p
500 you could obviously go and simply
just buy a low cost index of the s p 500
if it's going to outperform the hedge
funds but in good times like we saw in
2021 where there was 77 zero times that
the s p 500 hit an all-time high it's
really hard to outperform basically if
you're just long you're going to get 29
the hedge funds then have to time
markets they have to go in and out they
got to be short they've got a hedge in
case there's a drawdown and so naturally
they're going to lag in bull markets
where the hedge funds really outperform
is when they're able to avoid
catastrophe if there are market crashes
so seeing this is not necessarily
surprising but it means that if you were
an investor in these funds without even
accounting for the fees you still did
not outperform the s p 500. is this a
argument as to why people shouldn't
invest in hedge funds or is this what we
should expect in a bull market like this
where it basically just goes up all year
and so naturally because of fees and
because they're actually hedging we're
gonna get some underperformance of uh
the s p
i mean there's a lot of evidence
pointing that you're better off just
doing broad-based index funds and stuff
like that if you just want broad
exposure to the market like you could
just buy the s p and you obviously would
have outperformed 90 of these people so
when you take funds and uh when you take
fees into account and everything like
that a lot of the times when the market
rips like this you're much better off
buying the index the question becomes
like if you want to do more exotic
products if you want to look outside of
just equities if you want exposure to
other industries if you uh if the market
doesn't explode right if it goes down if
we see an 08 or 09 or something like
that and granted the returns aren't
always this kind of disproportionate but
ultimately a lot of the time you're just
way better off buying the s p or an etf
or an index fund of some type that's
more broad based and you don't have to
pay fees on or not as high as fees joe
what do you think a lot of hedge funds
made money this year a lot of headphones
also lost money this year right s p
returned 29 and these headphones got
paid
on a two percent fee of 4.5 trillion
dollars they got paid 90
billion dollars to manage your money 90
billion and most of them didn't
outperform i don't use a hedge fund i
think some people it's it's good if you
don't have the time or the energy but um
if you want broad-based exposure to the
market you can uh you can just do that
yourself problem laughing because you
just hit them with i don't use a hedge
fund i thought you're gonna follow up
with i am the hedge fund
i was like a little lion moves
eventually i paid myself the management
fee this year
you charged us all two and twenty yeah
yeah i never performed them and
outperformed dave you should hit him
with a three and 30 if you won't pay
yourself hey 2020 a year was a good uh
good year for my portfolio what we
should do is just measure bitcoin's
return over the last decade versus the
average hedge fund return because i'm
sure it's not even in the same strategy
it's not even close not even close the
other piece of this too i think is that
most of these hedge funds uh one of the
things that i always ask people is how
much of the hedge fund manager actually
has their own
uh net worth or their own portfolio
invested in their own hedge fund so
there's especially in the older uh days
you know a decade or two ago there's a
lot of hedge fund managers like look i'm
managing my own money you can invest
alongside me and this is 80 90 percent
of my portfolio you know there's some
private equity or maybe some real estate
or or something outside of our hedge
fund but for the most part this is how i
invest my money and i have just as much
skin in the game if not more on a
percentage basis than you do now there's
not so much right some of it's just mega
funds so you get people who are raising
billions and billions of dollars but
also on top of that you get uh just the
management fees are so uh damn high that
they end up actually having the ability
to not put as much money in themselves
and so it just changes the way that the
game's played but ultimately the
market's just manipulated they're going
to continue to push asset prices higher
and so a hedge fund meaning that it's
hedged it's going to lag out and not
outperform in a bull market and that's
what we're seeing happen over this year
yeah i also think it's important like
they're not all these hedge funds aren't
necessarily pegged to the s p and are
trying to beat the s p right so it's
kind of unfair in some instance to claim
that you know every single fund was out
there trying to beat the s p that's not
what they're there for right but i think
a lot of the time when you just think
about the hedge funds in general a lot
of them are optimizing just for
management fees right and how much money
can we get in here how much money can we
not lose right and give a give a rate of
return that is equal or greater than
what people are expecting so they keep
their money and you continue to get your
management fee and your business
continues to grow with assets under
management so i think ultimately like it
depends on what you're optimizing for if
you're an older individual looking for
exposure to a bunch of different assets
compound your capital over time and you
don't mind paying that fee sure go ahead
but i think for a lot of younger people
like they're gonna opt out of this
structure because there's so many
different options now not only with
digital uh assets like bitcoin and
others but also just index funds and all
this other stuff that's out there
there's so many different options that
you can go put park your money into uh
where you won't get charged these fees
and these fees when you look at it over
time like i don't have any charts here
but if you look at uh if you just google
like what these fees do to your total
return it eats away at it over time so i
think a lot of people are waking up to
the idea that not only they are
underperforming in bull markets that
we've seen the last few years but
ultimately the fees that people are
being charged are eating away at their
total return